it's National Unity day in Russia
moscow's red square cleared for the Men
in Black
[Music]
using his people's patriotism and their
apparent enthusiasm to go and fight
[Music]
among 300 000 people 318
000 people have already been mobilized
why three hundred and eighteen thousand
because volunteers go the flow of
volunteers is not declining
foreign but all of them need training
here's some of that for those lucky
enough to get it in the Leningrad region
around Saint Petersburg new recruits
learning how to move through and clear a
space instructed by a man called Nikolai
formerly Police Special Forces who we
meet in Saint Petersburg
we instructed about 1200 people for two
months this is military policing these
are checkpoints on the new territories
of our beautiful state conducting
dialogues related to a conflict
situation
it's the opening ceremony of a grand new
center belonging to the Wagner group
billed as a kind of patriotic hub for
fresh thinking on all things defense
for so long now a lot of the reporting
around Wagner has tended to describe it
as this shadowy private military company
not so shadowy anymore with this huge
shiny new headquarters here in St
Petersburg literally called PMC Wagner
Center even though private military
companies are still illegal under the
Russian Constitution
but Wagner has come out into the open
all guns blazing with films glorifying
the group's work in Ukraine a man who
runs it though Evgeni prigojin not in
attendance but apparently filmed
recently recruiting Russian convicts to
fight
those who arrive on the first day and
say I'm not where I'm supposed to be we
label them a deserter and execute them
by firing squad pregosian said that
deserters would be shot is that okay
if he deserts he is a criminal if not
here then there the death penalty awaits
him
mobilizing convict was illegal but Putin
just signed it into law mercenary
companies still illegal have glistening
corporate hubs laws bent to fit round
reality as this terrible fight drags on
Diana Magnus St Petersburg Russia